[Applause] the AO 14 goals for Seattle last
year Jones rebound free for Bard he winds up
with it in the corner back for vasic Bard
Nifty pass for blassic with a lot of room
he put it on out rebound goal Ryan Donado has
Chicago on the board and Conor Bard's got his
first National Hockey League point he'll
have an assist on the pass the vasic the
rebound bounces Odin Ryan Donado 30 goals
the last two years in Seattle the 14 you
mentioned last year is on the doorstep to
take the rebound and put it away the pens
are on the ice a long time they're a little
slow there's the pass from Bard the shot the
save the rebound and Donato's cut the lead in
half and Connor Bard in his National Hockey
League debut has a point on the board and
Donato's got his first as a Chicago Blackhawk
Ryan denado the son of Ted denado
longtime NHL player now the head
coach at Harvard Ryan played for his dad
who's one of the great guys in hockey